bella a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video io sono fan ejei
pagine domenica andiamo avanti con happy
meals stranamente era che oggi non ho
nessuna promessa da dire la che è
impossibile e quindi direi di iniziare
subito e questo è un evento a credibile
sono sempre da dire premi invece
stavolta niente ne scelgo una caso laga
non so cos'è cos'è ragazzo lug fenomeno
a questo gioco per il primo andato il
secondo pure il test ha neanche ora
l'hanno beccato madonna che mito e devo
riuscire che browser nostro gioco
oh mio dio se ok no un cazzo proprio 0 è
di fai cagare
ma dai volete dirmi che non ne becca
neanche 1 mag dai cazzo allora fermino
concentrare vai cia puoi fare poi è
dietro 25 è un traguardo devo riuscire a
beccare che cola bene ce l'ho fatta è
stata una cosa assurda
mi sono divertito troppo cazzo devo
riuscire a trovare le harley impossible
ma io che ci vuoi fare
cazzo mi ha preso ma preso ma no io non
demordo
io non demordo vai vuoi vedere che anche
da gita m'incazzo sto pedalando dai
nomadi of cycle survival cos'è questo
corsa a ostacoli sopravvive ragazzi fa
tutto padre di york praticamente è sta
giocando soltanto lui
vai cos'è caraglio che devi muoverti
veloce alza le braccia cosa cazzo fai
gli occhi
[Musica]
baiocchi cos'è cos'è oh mio dio cosa
cazzo è successo grande gli occhi il tuo
compito e distrarmi la e di st vai vai
così vai coda york sei un assassino di
merda dillo che l'hai fatto apposta
strato ti sta bene io mi giu la lega che
si livelli li amo perché sono no sense
in una maniera incredibile
e cosa devo fare cad uscì no no io ci
vado con la bici ci vado con la pace
sono ribelle devo sopravviverai cosa
vuol dire sopravvive io certo che
sopravvive ma scherzi vado padre di luca
sto punto tanto ormai è è lui la star di
questa è lui la star di questo episodio
devo allora devi essere veloce in cosa
devo essere veloce ma è ovvio addio con
in lavatrice
cos'è ma dai stavolta ci passo stavolta
the sun che non c'è o mio dio è partita
una spada a caso non si sa da dove mai
partita mai grande se ce lo fa al mio
dio
madonna come sia stato la mia mamma mia
che però che proprio che pro
credi ma le orche andato sinceramente
non me ne frega un cazzo
c'è una freccia conficcata nel cervello
ma sono ancora vivo
pedala pedala che cola
[Musica]
[Applauso]
hold on the longest cos'è sta roba devo
è trattieni ti su quello più lungo ha
trattenuti più a lungo ho capito cos'è
devo trattenersi ma devo tenermi una
persona o fermati mi tengo al tuo culo
by cos'è anzi no la sua veramente così
mi uccido mi sa è di edith è
attentissima è di attesa visto che non
dovevo tenermi ragazza non ho mai fatto
suo livello mi pare grandissima le voci
di addio ragas sono come cazzo dove sono
diventate una sacca cos'è sono diventate
uno zaino kay perfetto mi sono aperto
devo riuscire a trattenermi più a lungo
uno stralcio palla piede
devo resistere alla ragazza tenermi io
contro la besa ce la posso fare
ce la posso fare vai cos'è lo pensano
prese incredibile lob e se vai è grande
ma è ancora viva è ancora viva la che
non è ancora morta ancora di che si
tiene e non demorde fino all'ultima dai
che perde tutto il sangue ce la può fare
run the world ma ora che mi sa che
questo ok questo oh mio dio poi così
sotto perfetto mi stavo ci avete
presente quando dovete reciclare
qualcosa in questo caso ha funzionato
raga sword tra o ci vuole come al solito
un episodio di hoepli se no non si può
chiamare dio che cosa o mio dio
cos'è è solo lì così sotto ma cosa cazzo
oddio babbo natale che a roma ci pensa
sta succedendo rai che sta facendo tutto
lui è arrivato in faccia mi oddio cosa
ho la testa di babbo natale perché è
caduto volevo lanciarla ragazzi non sto
facendo niente non so ho lanciato una
spada
la stato lanciato perché oggi ho vinto
stanno facendo tutto loro ragazzi
guardate oddio
[Musica]
ho preso una donna o pre cosa fa
ok ragazzi cos'è questo cioè non l'ho
già che col porsche devo prendere allora
fermo che sto guidando con la testa io
sto guidando con la lingua ragas giro al
volante laica box
devo andare qua mi sento tipo questa
strada e gta 5
raga questo bel trailer di gta 5
incredibile ci siamo o mio dio fatta
guidare con la lingua solo nonno ciak
solo lui
raga vi giuro che vive sola ma cos'è
questa imposta per farvi j
ci siamo è un il prossimo per me ciao fa
vi sono un tuo ammiratore dal primo
video vediamo se riesce a farlo a non
pensare che io non ci riesca per questa
cosa è perfetto come non mi è partita la
testa
oh mio dio devo farcela in qualche modo
allora devo aspettate un attimo pezzi
dai che ci porta tra cos'è favi grazie a
the stone è importante
va bene ma se riesco a finire a livello
magari sono contento anch'io
allora fermatevi un attimo di riuscire
fermi fermi maledizione circi
maledizione fermi a credere di non
riuscirci a fare non mi deludere non ci
riesco mai quelli in cui non ci riesco
non ci gioco più ok ho capito questo è
impossibile
raga io i miei impossible non riesco
allora faccio questo che un altro
impossible non dedicato a me e vi giuro
che questo riesco a farlo sicuro ma non
riesco a fare quelli che dedicano a me è
impossibile alla guardate guardate
guardate cazzo ma comunque a parte tutto
io non riesco a fare soltanto i livelli
che mi dedicano non so perché è un
mistero e dolci mai così michael se
vedete che vedete che non riesco a fare
soltanto di quelli che dedicano a me
tutti gli altri ci riesco raga questo è
un mistero
e assurdo vediamoli riuscirà a vai col
padre york dai dai che mi sono depresso
dopo non essere riuscito a fare mia
livello porta un po di gioia
vai con gli occhi non ci serve vai così
senza di lui ed a madonna o mio dio
no non ci voglio credere
non ci vuoi mano raga ma possibili ma
posso morire cos'è fighting arena questo
mischia perfetto ragazzi no bastardo non
allacciate alla riscossa la femmina
brutto stronzo che devo cambiare
personaggio a si può fare solo con eddy
spalle di marco lelli è impossibile tipi
hanno tutti in faccia allora fermi un
attimo devo schivarlo vai così madonna
come ho fatto per togliti cazzola no
tagliente e allora ci mando lui avanti
seriamente però non riuscire a schivare
gli occhi maledetto s'è guadagnato un
pene e allora aspettate ok grandissimo
gli ultimi ai quasi ucciso
è in questa posizione molto molto
ambiguo cazzo cosa sull'addio raga cos'è
cos'è sta roba
cos'è caso
direi di fare l'ultimo rock swing con
eddy già che ci siamo
the rock swing king sono ovviamente è di
rop swinging che scherziamo è il
migliore raga tra l'altro veramente
volevo ringrazia se il braccio di eddy e
molliccio non è colpa mia ma letizia vai
e ti fa qualcosa di epico cos'era male
di mamma mia e di sempre
raga devo attenderli più in allenamento
perché questi qui se non si allenano ora
diventano più buoni a nulla sono
diventano dei buoni a nulla maledizione
non so no è di cosa mi fa non puoi farmi
questo brutto stronzo non puoi maledetto
oggi non sono nemmeno per il of swing
allora facciamo spartan assassin come
lui hanno aspettate ce lo slow motion ce
lo slow motion
questo lo devo fare devo schivarli alla
fermi cielo nel pene ma sono vivo ok
allora feb ci sono sopravvissuto hai
qualche problema sono sopravvissuto
ok perfetto ora che faccio l'ultimo
spartan assassin obiettivo
cos'è vai e fai vedere che è l'ultimo
vero samurai è ok perfetto ci sembra di
essere più sulla scopa
oddio
soppressi tutti di culo ma non vale dove
infilzarli se non va bene
vai e fai vedere che sei in grado di
piazzare tutta sta gente
by cos'è veramente lalut sei perfetto ok
non sei capace west race for fa vj laica
faccio l'ultimo poi finisci vediamo se
ce ne sono altri se non altro cento per
cento impossible fa vj lega ce ne sono
troppi però vabbè tanto li tengo tutti
prima o poi li farò eva le faccio questo
dai mi piace che sono nello nella home
di di happy meals che famosissimo e
quindi mica incredibile ogni volta mi
fone effettuato un attento alla testa
watch your head
perfetto mai se sto attento ce l'ho
fatta era questo ce l'ho fatta invece
cosa ti credevi che non fossi capa cosa
succede
sono ancora non era finito ma dicendo
male non era finita ma io pensavo ma io
ero tranquillo non pensavo maledizione
mi hai fregato
devo riuscire a farcela terminato non
possono riuscirci è in poi dobbiamo
sfatare questo mito che io non riesco a
fare i livelli facci per me è ok ragazzo
una tattica
ok perfetto è partito gli occhi quindi
la tattica è andato a [ __ ] bravo gli
occhi bravo agli occhi non ci credo c'è
riuscito ha distratto gli arpioni
grandissimo a qualcosa sei servito nella
tua inutile vita stronza ce l'ho fatta
chi è che diceva che non riuscivo a fare
i miei livelli puttanate a nera gaio di
legge posso finire qui
come al solito 6 v dove è piaciuto
lasciato un commento mi piace anche alla
pagina di facebook e come in ogni video
trovate nella descrizione sera siete
carichi di schede e noi ci vediamo un
prossimo video bene ragazzi